and there he is sonny gray
who will make his third opening day
start in his career
his prior two were really sharp back
when he was with oakland in 2014 and
2015
he put together one of the better
seasons we've seen from a pitcher last
year in the national league he put
together
one of the better seasons we've seen
from a pitcher last year in the national
league
that loads the bases no ouch recorded in
the home half of the first
matt boyd in some serious trouble and he
is hit with a pitch it will bring in a
run
and cincinnati with a one nothing lead
on a walk a hit and two hit batsman
and mike mustakis is trying to make his
mark in his first at-bat as a red
3-2 to mastakis and he'll send it to
shallow right that's going to fall and
score another run for cincinnati and
then it's spiked into the ground by
mavin
it comes votto it's two-nothing maven
didn't get a great read
now mustaches goes after the first pitch
same spot in left center
and castellanos will come in it's
three-nothing cincinnati
one new red drives in another goes after
the first pitch trying to get it away
it's middle middle
now it's
he pulls that one deep left forget about
it
cj crone muscles up for a solo home run
and it's three to one you're gonna give
them up as a pitcher that's how you give
them up you don't even
waste your time looking around seeing if
that's going to be caught
red's half of the 4th inning cincinnati
up 3-1
and that is clock to left tough to see
it
but kristen stewart loves it and smiles
doesn't stick the landing though
i'll tell you what that's a great play i
mean we're seeing it here
on tv with the glare and you can only
imagine what that's like coming straight
at him
joey vado leads off against matthew boyd
here in the fifth
that ball is in the air to right field
by vato
and he has his first home run here in
2020.
a couple of hits tonight lined into a
double play
and now launches one to right center
field to make it a 4-1
cincinnati lead the 2-2
hit hard what a play by goodra gets to
his feet
throws a strike to krone oh you hit it
hard nick but
take a seat kid right that's what nico's
telling him
and now the introduction of the newest
cincinnati red
shogo akiyama he is making his mlb debut
a six-time gold glove winner in japan
galvez and casalli are on and shoko
hakiyama welcome to the big leagues
his first at-bat brings in a run and
makes it 5-1 cincinnati
galvez comes in and he fought back from
down 0-2
there's the drive into right field and
michael
moustakis what a cincinnati reds debut
three hits four runs batted in
for mike foreign
the only thing missing chris would be
those fans right now 43
000 of them collectively with the move
nate jones facing harold castro
contact hitter and he makes contact on
the first pitch drives it to deep
left and the catch is made shogo akayama
with the rbi hit
and now the sweet play with the glove
wow
that is doing it on both ends that's not
an easy catch going right into that
wall five-time gold glover in japan
he's now made 34 starts as a reds
pitcher and
none of those starts has he given up
more than four runs that is
a little bit of consistency going on
right there a new pitcher
for the cincinnati reds brooks raley
the lefty is on to work the ninth for
cincinnati against jonathan scope
miguel cabrera and cj crone
scope is struck out twice and singled
this one will be in fair touring shallow
center for mustache
jam shot pop up raley will get it in
foul ground
and that's the old ball game and even
though marty brennaman is no longer
around chris just one more time for old
times sake how about this one belongs to
the reds
sounds good to me sounds good to me hey
i miss your dad bob i do too we miss him
a lot
the reds take down the tigers on opening
day 7-1 your final score it was
all about the off-season additions got
an rbi
shogo off the bench a pitch hit single
to knock in a run and a great play
defensively
and sunny gray setting the tone right
from the get go